we just heard Jonathan Ashworth saying
that look if you're an experienced
politician you won't get drawn into
making predictions or see if I have any
more luck with you what's a good night
for the live Dems and the local
elections
well I think we can make real really
good gains actually Sophie
um the last time these seats before we
made big gains we made over 700 games
four years ago in these particular
Council Awards but I've been going up
and down the country I've been to
Stockport and greater Manchester I've
been to Holland or Yorkshire I've been
down to Lewis and Eastbourne all around
the country and what we're hearing on
the doorsteps is lifelong conservatives
really quite cross they feel they've
been taken for granted they feel the
government is out of touch whether it's
on the cost of living crisis or the NHS
crisis and they feel that the little
Democrats are coming up with really good
ideas they like our candidates who are
it's a really good local activists who
represent their areas really well so I'm
feeling very positive that the party's
got momentum and I think we will make
good gains okay well that's the pitch
and you're pretty clear at your election
launch what the plan to get there is you
were sort of pictured driving a tractor
through a blue wall so obviously got on
those they're conservative blue wall of
seats in your sights are you going to go
after dominant rap
well Dominic Robb ought to resign as an
MP and face a by-election and if he's
not prepared to do that to enable his
constituency Walton to have a the MP
they deserve I think the government
should withdraw the whip from him
otherwise they're sending a message that
that bullying is somehow okay in the
conservative party but when it comes to
local elections there's the elmbridge
district council elections in his
constituency I think we will make big
gains from the conservatives in those
council elections and at the next
general election we will defeat Dominic
Raab well it's interesting isn't it
because I feel like there's a tactical
question for the Germans about which
kind of Voters you go for and it's very
clear from the launch and listen to what
you say that you do see conservative
seats as a particular Target so does
that mean are you to the right or to the
left of the labor party
we are putting forward a liberal
Democrat uh position whether it's on the
economy dealing with the cost of living
we were the first party today I'm just
gonna if I may I'm just gonna jump in
because I do kind of feel if you can't
answer that question some people will be
asking what is the point of the liberal
Democrats you've got to cut through
you're the smallest smaller party the
third biggest party you've got to have a
clear message surely that's always when
you've done best on things such as the
Iraq one you can't even tell me if
you're to the right or the left of Labor
okay no we we have a very clear message
you're defining in terms of left and
right I'm not accepting that definition
I'm saying we have positive positive
policies on the economy uh to help
people with their energy bills to help
businesses who are struggling with their
energy bills we've got really
distinctive policies on the Health
Service let me give you one
um everyone knows that in order to sort
out the NHS we've got to sort out social
care there's 165 000 vacancies in Social
care only the little Democrats have put
forward an idea that there should be a
special minimum wage for carers two
pounds an hour extra on top of the
national minimum wage to deal with that
crisis because if we deal with a crisis
in Social care Sophie that will help a
lot of patients be discharged from
hospital they're waiting days weeks in
hospital when they should be going out
because it's not the carers to look
after them that puts extra pressure on
the NHS it wastes money and is not good
for those patients so liberal Democrats
are coming up with really attractive
policies on our health services on the
economy and that's distinctive from both
the other parties is
I mean I I absolutely concede that
social care is a hugely important thing
in this country but I guess my question
is a time when you need to cut through
as a smaller party is a bit more money
for carers really going to do that if
you look at the latest polling for
example you know you can see the labor
party doing very well compared to the
conservative party in the polling the
lib Dems I mean you're still kind of
bumbling along the bottom and I'm trying
hard to differentiate your line there
between all the other smaller parties
well so if you when we get to actual
elections which I think is really what
matters we are cutting through big time
so the local elections last year which
party made the biggest gains and these
elections were across England Scotland
and Wales it was the liberal Democrats
making the most gains at three Palm two
by-elections in the last two years in
True Blue areas like in Cheshire and
Amsterdam and buckinghamshire it was
liberal Democrats who beat the
conservatives in North Shropshire seek
the territories of hell for 200 years we
cut through and we won that seat in East
Devon in different Honiton last summer
we overturned a majority the biggest
majority ever overturned at a palm tree
by election in British electoral history
we were getting cut through and beating
the conservatives and what I'm seeing as
I go around the country and talk to
people we are the ones who are getting
the those lifelong stories switching to
us and in vast ways of the country both
of the council elections in May and the
general election whenever it comes
presumably next year it's liberal
Democrats who are the ones who are best
placed to beat the conservatives and we
will get that cut through and beat those
conservatives looking ahead to you next
year the general election which does
feel quite unpredictable
if labor falls short of an outright
majority with the lib Dems enter a
coalition with them
look so if in my job as far as I've said
throughout my leadership is to be
conservative MPS we have a positive
liberal Democrat agenda and that's what
we'll be standing on and you know when I
go around the country and talk to voters
they feel the conservatives have taken
the for granted liberal Democrats are
not going to make that mistake we're
going to work really hard to make sure
we get as many little Democrat MPS
backer after the next election and beat
as many concert MPS as possible I could
not have been clearer well you haven't
been that clear in answering the
question that I pose which is would the
lib Dems go into Coalition with labor
well the Democrats job is to beat
conservatives the next election there
are one of your seats where we're up
against uh labor like Sheffield Hallam
but the vast majority of seats that we
can win the next election in my judgment
are against the conservatives and I want
to focus relentlessly on that I I think
the conservatives have let down our
country very very badly that's what
conservative voters are telling us
whether it's only economy on the Health
Service on the the environment for
example I mean here's an issue we're
being cutting through Sophie the
outrageous way that can the
conservatives have allowed water
companies to pump their filthy sewage
into our rivers and seas has really
really angered many many people and it's
been the liberal Democrats leading on
that campaign in Parliament in the local
elections and I'm delighted that many
parts of the media now following were
the issue that liberal Democrats have
first put on that table okay that's a
simple thing if you vote liberal
Democrat you're going to get strong
position on the environment okay I'm
very clear where you are on the water
I'm still not clear about whether you'd
enter a coalition with labor because
some would say that look if you want to
make impact on things such as the
environment then you've got to be in
government would you enter the Coalition
with labor it's a really clear question
yeah and I'm giving you a clear answer
the more liberal Democrats
no because I want people to vote liberal
Democrat to both to compete be
conservative and peace and to get
liberal Democrat policies and I've
outlined a number of those policies to
you today and that's the job of
political party surely is to stand on a
set of policies on a set of values and
put them into it to the electorate and
hopefully when seats so MPS can do that
in Parliament if you don't feel able to
answer the question about whether you've
done to a coalition just just say look
I'm not going to answer that question
because I I'm trying to I'm trying to
work out if I'm supposed to be reading
between lines here or if I just don't
get it would you enter a clinic
it's quite closer because when I go up
and down the country talking to people
on the economy on the Health Service on
the environment that's not what people
are asking me they're asking me how are
you going to deal with without problems
yeah but but yeah I know I know you are
but what I feel is that liberal
Democrats and all politicians frankly
should respond to the electorate make it
clear where they stand on those issues
and not take voters for granted I mean
in many ways your question is taking
voters for granted I'm not going to do
that I want to make sure that we earn
people's vote over the weeks and months
ahead so at the next general election we
can get rid of this a shocking
government who's failing our country is
just so out of touch with people who
can't afford food bills can't afford
their energy bills and are desperately
trying to get into get that hospital
treatment they need